big south paw who's towing the slab for
the green and gold shaw manaya as we
mentioned at the top of the broadcast
whose season is trending upward very
nicely here's the wind up by sean he
deals to brantley and bradley it's a fly
ball left center playable ariana going
over in the alley he's right there three
five balls astros go down in the top of
the first with the a's coming up in the
bottom half and the ball is in the right
hand of jose or kitty making his second
start on the season
two pitch how about that start by jose
or kitty a couple of fly outs and a
strikeout
swing and a miss it that is the first
strikeout for seanaya
up the middle
la stella's there
and that'll do it nine up nine down for
sean manaya
here comes the 1-1 fastball at the right
again and this one in play for reddick
back toward the wall on the track and he
kisses up against the padding and makes
the catch right next to the 3 30 side
sends this ball in the air does jonah
heim to center field easy play for
george springer and urkini matching
shaun manaya through three no score it's
the fourth inning
it's that one right up the middle nice
play by la stella throws on the run in
bregman's retirement well yeah and if
you're alex bregman right now you're
saying to yourself well shift happens
and we've got a la stella there
the stella and shallow right here's the
2-2 pitch bounce up the middle past
mania but right there is simeon sets his
feet oh it is a pinder rather in the
shifting of the shift he throws the
first oh five three on the other side of
second base that is 12 in a row where
it's hired by mania no base runners yet
in this one here comes a 3-2
change up just outside quite a close
take by marcus and he introduces the
ball game to first base
first base runner for either side
that ball hit to center field hit pretty
well but george has it lined up puts it
away and straight away center grossman
retired for the final out couple of
walks couple men left on base
there's a line drive into the glove of
pinders he grabs it on a high backhand
and now the o2 delivery here it is and
that's on the outside corner fastball
ring him up perfect pitch tucker knew it
kyle tucker i see you perusing can i
help you no thanks just looking
and correa went around and he went back
to the changeup and that's the strikeout
so
15 up 15 down
can it he's got to base it
that's the first hit in the game for
either team
and here's jonah high
1-1 to heim and heim lifts this one
pretty deep to right center field redick
is racing over so with springer and
springer makes the run and grab on the
warning track
george springer taking away extra bases
from jonah heim and the inning comes to
an end
chamonix delivers to josh redick and he
grounds one just fair down the right
field line for the first hit of the game
for the astros redick is on his way to
second base with a lead off double so
runners at first and third and maldonado
the batter
and he hits the ball hard but at the
second baseman they're gonna be able to
turn two reddick's gonna cross the plate
[Applause]
a little half swing on the ground correa
up the middle has to hurry and he gets
simeon by his stride carlos correa
oh matt olson the batter the fish to
olson by her kitty swung on a high drive
right field reddick is going back
reddick at the track right to the wall
he will turn and watch and olson has hit
it out well you just can't give away a
free pass to extend the inning and
that's exactly what happened all aboard
next stop pound town
bregman hits it in the hole
it's backhanded
simeon's throw right there and nicely
done by marcus simeon
[Applause]
driven
to right
cannas there fights it a little bit
makes the catch and it's a three-up
three-down inning for sean manaya
seventh inning stretch time coming up
sean manaya just wondering run in 70s
tremendous effort by mania
best of the year
here comes chad pinder the third baseman
this one's gonna sneak through into
center field for a base hit cannon's
gonna come in to score the a's at an
insurance run they lead three to one
chad pinder with a big knock
and there's that big curve ball
see chad get his foot down just kind of
wait for that thing to make its way
down into the strike zone and hammer
time
[Applause]
hey grossman just yeah he's taking some
chances over there and the astros might
want to look at this and joe espada says
hey we got something he's out
overturned good challenge by the astros
as we go to the ninth heading these lead
three one liam hendricks on to try to
save it
loriano
finishes the series in style with a
sliding play
three up three down ninth inning
and the athletics
the athletics have closed out a great
five games against the astros
[Applause]